[Musique]
le bac arrive est paraît-il qu'à la
bibliothèque départementale
les lycéens trouvera havre de paix
parfaite pourrait viser en plus à saint
denis il fait grise mine
un vrai temps pour réviser allons
rencontrer ces jeunes à l'intérieur
c'est le bruit du silence un silence
même reposant pour certains
l'ambiance est très studieuse et pas le
temps de discuter
moi je suis hyper concentré
je comprends
mon oral d'anglais
quelques lycéens accepte quand même de
lever le nez de leur cahier
qu'est ce que c'est que tu sais plus
calme et puis on entre amis donc ça me
motive ça va franchement ça va je gère
pour l'instant et quand d'autres
prennent une pause dehors c'est le
moment idéal pour bavarder voilà je suis
venu cette semaine mais le matin vient
je révise après la prise d'échantillons
jeu mais j'ai un planning du coup chaque
jour que je viens de gt matière à
réviser différentes obligé d'avoir un
peu de stress est normal le stress fait
partie du parti de ce à quoi
mais enfin là pas de raison pour que
vous voulez pas quoi ils travaillent
pour bages et en bibliothèque pour pour
travailler voir mon bac avec mention
très bien donc ouais bah voila je bosse
et puis voilà on verra la note les
résultats le sens que j'ai la pression
ah oui surtout mes parents ils mettent
beaucoup de pression et
faut avoir son bac quoi c'est la base
c'est là où les choses que les chasseurs
10 commence donc je m'accroche et je
fais tout pour réussir mon bac
c'est ce que je désire le plus sûr le
plus non mais c'est un moment important
dans dans la queue dans le cheminement
d'un étudiant donc je l'espère que je
l'aurais de faire médecine
les bergers c'est ça pour veiller
jusqu'à 19 heures et oui sérieux jusqu'à
19 heures la bibliothèque départementale
s'est toujours voulue et nos ventes pour
permettre aux jeunes de travailler au
maximum
elles restent ouverts plus tard le soir
en cette période le conseil
départemental encourage les lycéens
durant cette étape de leur parcours
bon courage à tous
[Musique]